Now we've got everything we need to play basic sound effects with no unfly
audio processing.
[SOUND].
The only thing we have left to do, is to adjust the volume of various effects
based on where they happen in the game world. For example, when my character
picks up quad damage, I hear it at full volume. [SOUND]. An explosion that
happens in the distance may only be heard at half volume. [SOUND]. And it won't
even hear an enemy who picks up an energy canister on the far edges of the map.
Now, Grits uses a pretty simple distance calculation based on the ViewRect
side. We want to be able to hear the sound, within the screen radius at full
volume. Then, we'll want to scale down the volume to zero, as we reach two
times the radius. Finally, you won't hear any sound at all outside of that
radius.